(atmosphere humming softly)
- [Sam] All right.
Hello, and welcome everyone.
Make sure you're all in the
right room, this is IND395,
"Accelerating Game Design Reviews
with Generative AI and LLM Agents."
So, I am Sam Patzer, I'm a
Solution Architect at AWS,
and I'm joined here with Christina!
- [Christina] Hi everyone, I'm Christina,
and I'm also a Solutions Architect at AWS.
- [Sam] So, I wanna just
ask the room a few questions
before we fully get started.
Who here has ever built a game before?
Awesome, we got a few folks.
All right, who here has
written a design doc before?
Requirements doc, whatever name
you wanna sign it, yep, yep.
All right, I see a lot more for folks,
all right, perfect, awesome.
Well today, we're gonna
kind of be reviewing
kind of how that maps
to some of the software
engineering practices
that you use, as well
as game design as well.
So, let's take a look at our agenda.
First off, we're gonna
introduce to everyone
what is a game analyst.
What does that mean,
what does that mean to the industry?
And also how it maps back to
software engineering as well.
Then kind of we will go over
an overview of what are we building today.
We'll go into what tools are
we gonna use in our toolbox,
and then actually spend some time
doing some live coding for y'all.
After that, we'll have some
time hopefully for some Q&A.
If not, we'll also be outside
to answer any Q&A as well.
So, let's dive into what is
the role of a game analyst?
The modern game analyst
serves both an interpreter
and a storyteller.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that they are able to take
the business goals and the player goals
and map that back to a
story that they want to tell
across the industry.
So, they wanna translate
things like player data,
business data, QA, design
docs, everything else like that
into a boil down doc,
and their role is to be
able to translate any doc
into the those different areas,
and be able to give feedback on it.
So, for those that have written
requirement docs before,
usually, typically engineers are the ones
writing the requirements docs,
and then you have someone
else come in and review it.
Game analyst's job is to be
the reviewer of those docs.
So, for those that aren't
familiar with the game analyst,
we've broken it down
into four competencies.
The first one is focused on lore.
Lores, their entire idea is
to validate that this update
or this idea fits into the game itself.
So, think about like, oh,
if we're adding a new race
into "New World," for example,
which we'll be using later on as example,
we're gonna be adding elves,
does that fit the lore of "New World?"
Next, we're gonna be looking
at QA or Quality Assurance.
Does this break anything in the game?
Is it valid to be in
the game, does it break?
Is it a new powered item?
Does it break other play tests?
This common problem that
always has to be solved
to make sure evaluated when
you approach the problem.
Finally, or the next one is game design.
Is this update fun?
Do players want to
engage with this update?
Make sure that we design
and build this game
in such a way that players
keep coming back to our game.
And finally, game strategy.
Does this fit into our
business needs, right?
Is this something that we
want to go forward and do
for business and strategy?
Does it fit like our
player retention models?
Does it bring new players in?
These are all questions
that the game analysts
should be able to answer as well.
With that, there's a lot
of current challenges
that have to happen with this.
The first one is slow duration.
During the back and forth
process of that early proposal,
there could be a lot of back and forth
due to incomplete information
that's unavailable.
The designers don't have
access to the same data sources
as the analysts do.
For example, the analysts might have docs
around the strategy that the
game designers might not have,
and they might know more
than the actual designers.
Finally, to take a game
analyst to available to be able
to review docs, it takes a
lot of time for them to learn
how to be able to review these docs.
So, everything from
learning knowledge about
what the game is, learning how,
what the content of that game is gonna be,
and all the different silos,
what we talked about previously,
as well as best practices
and methodologies for
reviewing those docs.
It takes a lot of time and energy
to bring someone up to speed.
And then finally, subjective,
feedback, bias do exist.
And so, when you have someone come,
and for example, review
a doc for "New World,"
they might review that
like, "Oh, this new edition
is not good for the game
because I'm a purist and I think
that all new updates are bad."
And that might influence their
decision-making to be bad.
Or if you're ever been in a design review
and someone is like, has the opinion about
what code language should be written in,
when objectively,
something else is better,
that's a bias that they're
bringing into that doc review.
So that's kind of what we're looking at
when you get that subjective feedback.
So, how are we gonna build it today?
Well, we're gonna first start off
by building four different
specialized agents.
These agents, their purpose
is to only evaluate the doc
that we're providing, and it's the lens.
So, for example, with lore
doc, it's only viewing that doc
from the lore perspective.
So that means is that we're
not taking consideration
our strategy, we're not taking
consideration our gameplay,
we're just taking
consideration of our lore.
And we're gonna do that
for every single bot.
Its whole purpose is to evaluate
that project with that idea.
And with that, we want to connect it
to different knowledge bases.
These different knowledge
bases contain a lot of detail
around how that lore exists
or that gameplay exists,
and it's gonna be very well
specialized in that area.
For example, with lore,
we have the entire "New
World" Wiki loaded into it,
which contains all the different knowledge
around "New World" inside of it.
After we have all these
bots, review those docs,
we then use an Orchestrator Agent,
which is the Game Analyst Agent
that then reviews the entire summary
and decides how it presented
back to the customer.
While the elves might
exist as a great solution
for the strategy doc, lore
it's against the lore overall.
And so, it has to evaluate
how do we evaluate strategy versus lore?
And there's different
ways to approach that,
and lore can then provide
feedback on how to do that better.
So, some of the benefits
behind this is that
we get an accelerated innovation cycle
because of the fact that
we're continuously chatting with bots,
identifying how we can spin
up things like, for example,
solve the lore problem or
solve the strategy problem.
We are getting collaborative intelligence
by having these bots work
together to be able to identify
different areas and different gaps.
And finally, it's unbiased, right?
You're literally reviewing
the information right from the source.
There is no bias saying that,
hey, I prefer this or I prefer this.
No, it's just straight from the source
on the knowledge base,
and it's pulling those in.
So, with all that, let's
take a look at our toolbox
to understand how we're
gonna build this layout.
- Alright, so we have the
what we're gonna build.
Now, I wanna talk about
how we can take this idea
and make it into a reality.
And we can do this by using
a few different tools.
Who here has heard about Strands?
Yeah, so Strands is our
open source framework
that is designed for
building agentic agents.
AI agents for
agentic applications.
It was designed, it's an
open source Python SDK
that was designed for ease of use.
So, you don't have to spend a ton of time
just trying to understand
how to use the framework.
It's supposed to be intuitive
so that you can get started
quickly for rapid prototyping.
It has seamless integration
with tools such as MCP servers.
How many of y'all had the chance
to use MCP servers before?
So yeah, you can use MCP
servers, you can have,
and it even is built
to be seamlessly integrated
with AWS services.
It was also designed to be flexible,
providing you with choice
of models and tools
that you can use.
The next tool we're gonna be using
is Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore is a
agentic platform for building,
deploying, and operating
AI agents at scale
in production ready.
AgentCore comes with a suite of services.
The ones that we're gonna be
specifically covering today
include Amazon Bedrock AgentCore Runtime,
which provides you with a
serverless hosting environment
for deploying and running
your agents on AWS
without having to manage
the complex infrastructure
that comes with agentic applications.
Additionally, we can enhance our agents
and make them context-aware
using AgentCore Memories,
which provides you
with a fully-managed memory infrastructure
for your context-aware agents.
And finally, for tracing and debugging,
we have Amazon Bedrock
AgentCore Observability,
which provides you a unified dashboard
where you can see all the
things such as traces.
So, you can figure out
the root causes of any of those errors
that usually takes a really
long time to find. (chuckling)
And then additionally, we can have,
we can see performance metrics
to see how well our agents are performing.
But you're not just limited to these tools
in Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
there are many other services
that you can bring into your workflow
to further increase the
capabilities of your agents.
So, just to list a few of them,
we have identity where
you can bring identity
and access management into your agents,
and even integrate them
with your own existing identity providers.
We have a code interpreter
for securely executing code
in a sandbox environment,
as well as browser capabilities.
And we have the AgentCore
gateway so that you can take
your existing APIs and Lambda functions,
and make them into MCP compatible tools,
pretty cool, right?
So, now that we've talked about
the tools, let's talk about
how we're gonna string these all together
to build our agentic solution.
So, how do I do the?
- [Participant] The laser button.
- [Christina] Laser button, all right.
Sorry guys.
So, to start off, we're gonna have
five different agents that
we're gonna be building.
And we can break these
into two different types of categories.
We're gonna have our specialized agents,
these are gonna be representing
our core competencies
that a game analyst would need.
So, we have a lore agent,
a quality assurance agent,
a gameplay agent, and a strategy agent.
And then, as our like main director,
we have our Orchestrator Agent,
and that is gonna be our game analyst.
The first AWS service that
we're gonna be leveraging,
well first actually, I'm
getting ahead of myself.
These agents are all gonna be written
with the Strands framework.
And the model that we're
gonna be using today
is we're gonna be using
the Anthropic Claude Sonnet 4.5 model.
With that, we're gonna
have all of these agents
are gonna be deployed
to their own Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore Runtime.
And then with that, each of our agents,
they're gonna need to have access
to various different data sources.
We have our game design documents
and business strategy documents.
These are gonna be stored
an Amazon S3 bucket.
And then, we also have
player behavior data
which could be stored
in maybe an Amazon
Redshift data warehouse.
With that, we're gonna
provide RAG capabilities.
Since this is at the basic
level, this is still a RAG
application because we need to go
and query data from our data sources.
And so with that, we're gonna use
the Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Bases,
how many of you all have
used that one before?
So, it's a really cool tool
because you can bring
basically your enterprise data
into your AI applications
in a very
easy way.
It provides you with the
ability to easily integrate
your AWS services
and make them into a vector data store.
And it does all the indexing for you.
It's a really good tool.
And so, we have all of these data sources,
youth leveraging Amazon
Bedrock Knowledge Bases,
and to provide us with our
standardized way for our agents
to be able to access these data sources,
we're gonna be leveraging an MCP server.
This one is specifically
designed by AWS for the demo,
and it's called the AWS Labs
Knowledge Base Retrieval.
And we're gonna be using that today
for interacting with these data sources.
And then finally, in order to provide
a better performance with our agents
and also a more personalized
experience for our users,
we're gonna be leveraging,
we're gonna make these
agents memory enabled
by leveraging the Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore Memory.
So for this, we're gonna have,
we can break our Memories up
into two different levels.
You'll see a little bit, this will make
a little bit more sense
when you see the demo.
But we're gonna have our
project-based memories,
and these are gonna be semantic facts.
And so, each of these agent runtimes
are gonna have their own set of facts
that they're gonna think about it
like as they're going
through their knowledge base,
they're gonna learn things about the data.
And so with that,
what the idea is,
we can make the performance
better because we can reduce
how often the agent goes all the way back
to the knowledge base
to retrieve information,
so over time, it'll get faster
and better at responding.
And then, at the user facing level,
we have our game analyst, right?
And so, we have two
different types of memory
that we can add here.
One is user preferences.
This can make the
experience better for users
by saving preferences
about that user.
For example, let's say
someone prefers having
bullet points in the responses
over paragraph forms.
You can have the agent remember that
so that it only is producing the outputs
that the responses in bullet points.
Additionally, we want the agent
to have awareness of
previous conversations.
And with that, we can
also add a session memory
to continue to,
so like in the case,
let's say someone gets disconnected,
they don't have to start the
conversation all over again,
or they can even refer to
like a previous conversation.
So, you have a more seamless
kind of interaction with it.
And then finally, throughout
this entire build process,
we leverage the Amazon Bedrock
AgentCore Observability
for all tracing and debugging,
and also monitoring the
performance of our agents.
All right?
I know that was a lot,
now we're gonna get to see that in action.
So, I'm gonna pass it on to you, Sam.
- [Sam] Perfect, all right.
Let's get this machine
up real quick, all right.
Go ahead and put demo.
Alright, so first off, we're
we're have a project portal
that we've created for this demo today.
This project portal,
we're gonna be demonstrating
all the different agents
and the different stages that
she kind of talked about here.
As I alluded, the first
thing we have to build
is obviously all the
different specialized agents.
So, what we're gonna do is we're
gonna create a new project.
This project is referenced
throughout the entire thing,
and the idea behind it is
that, as we talked about before
with the Memories, these
projects are all different silos
inside the actual project.
So, I've already pre-populated
some of the fields in here.
We're gonna be doing kind of the example
I referred to before.
We're gonna be adding elves
into our "New World" experience today.
For those that haven't played "New World,"
it's one of Amazon's MMOs
that really focus in on
like a human during the medieval time.
So, elves should not fit that well
and we'll see some
examples of that later on.
So, what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go down here
to the document for analysis.
I've already prepared a document,
I'll show that off to
y'all here real quick.
And inside this document,
you'll see we have
some different core features
that we are gonna be implementing.
Things like some
characteristics for the elves,
some cultural background,
just like a little brief thing about lore,
and some racial abilities
that come with being an elf as well.
Finally, there's some
customization options,
some technical requirements,
and a timeline.
For those that have ever
written requirements docs,
this is missing a lot of details,
and this should not pass
any someone's kind of bar
for running a doc.
But that's what we're gonna show today.
Is that this was obviously
not a well-written doc,
but that was the whole purpose
behind writing this doc
was just to show, hey!
I'm a brand new game designer,
I don't know what I'm doing.
Tell me how I can prove this doc.
So, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna go ahead
and copy this on over
to our wonderful tool
that we have over here
where we create a project.
And then we're gonna be prompted
with our agent configuration.
With us building out each
individual agent separately,
we've actually given
ourselves the power to be able
to select how we want to send
this document to the agents.
If, for example, I
already know my strategy
is a great strategy, we
don't want our strategy
to be evaluated,
or if we know more than
whatever else, we can just say,
"Hey, don't use that tool!
Don't enable it!"
So for this, for the demo today,
we're gonna start off
with removing analyst,
and we're gonna send it to
all three different agents individually.
We've also disabled
memory to kind of give us
an idea of what the performance looks like
without using any memory at all.
So, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna go ahead
and create that project.
And then with some demo
magic, instead of waiting
for this wonderful thing to
respond, I'm gonna hop on
over to our first page.
What we have over here is a overview.
The first thing it does
is it will send over
the entire doc we have over
to each one of our agents,
and each agent will automatically respond
with a detailed overview
of what it thinks about
our strategy doc.
And inside here, we can
then filter by gameplay,
lore and strategic,
these are all the separate bot overviews,
and it'll give us information around
how it feels it should fit.
So, let me scroll down a little bit
so y'all can see that!
It'll give us some details
and tell us things that we want to see.
For example, in the
gameplay it says, oh look,
there's some unprecedented
mechanics that I've added.
Well, that's not probably great
for other parts of the
gameplay, like for example, PVP,
it might introduce bad things.
Inside the faction system,
it might be hard to integrate,
and so on and so forth.
It gives us a whole overview
of all the different areas
that the gameplay might be
impacted by the strategy doc.
We're gonna do the same thing
and see that also in lore.
But one of the things that
interesting about lore
is that lore, we definitely
did not at all follow
the lore inside of "New World."
So, it's gonna call out
a lot of bad things.
Being like, ooh, this is bad no good.
And it's gonna go over
and say that this is just a bad update.
But then we go into strategic,
and strategic's like,
hmm, this is pretty good!
But then see that as the problem,
is that strategic likes
this, but lore does not.
And how do we combine all those together
and make sure that they're all valid?
And we're gonna get into
that a little later.
But first, I'm gonna hand off to Christina
and talk about how we built
these individual bots ourselves.
- [Christina] All right!
(mic shuffling)
Alright, so all of this.
So, I have our IDE open,
this is our lovely Kiro
that we just came out with.
How many of y'all had a chance
to play around with it yet?
Yeah, I really like this one.
So, let me make sure that
I open the right one.
So, we're gonna talk
about how to start
building our first agent.
And for this one,
we're gonna be looking
at the gameplay agent!
So, at a basic level, when you're building
an agent with Strands, there
are three key components
that are specific to a Strands agent.
You're gonna have tools,
you're gonna have a model,
and you're gonna have a system prompt.
Tools are gonna be things like,
they can either be custom tools,
that can be created through
like custom logic with like,
think like a function in a
class or something like that.
And it's designated with a tool decorator,
which you'll see in a little bit.
Or, tools can also be your MCP
servers that you want to use.
For this code, we're gonna
be actually leveraging,
we're gonna be leveraging the MCP server
for the Bedrock Knowledge
Base retrieval MCP server
that I alluded to earlier.
And so, we can see here, that
we have, basically what we'll do
is we would initialize the tool
by initializing a MCP client,
and then we would state which
MCP server we wanna use.
For this specific MCP server,
we have a few environmental variables
that you can enable.
For this one, we wanted to be able to
increase the accuracy of our
RAG process, and so we
have re-ranking enabled.
And then, the other piece we
have is an inclusion tag key,
because basically, the way
that this MCP server works
is you will tag your resource
with a specific tag that
you can define to say
this is part of my grouping for,
like what I want my agent
to be able to have access to
for querying using this MCP server.
For our model,
we have it up here,
and it is defined that we're
using the Amazon Bedrock model,
and we just have the model ID here.
And then, what I would say probably
the most important piece of
this entire thing, and I'm gonna
make this a little bit wider
for you, is this system prompt.
This system prompt is basically like,
think of this as like
the brain of your agent.
It's gonna define its personality,
it's gonna have its role
and instructions on how
it retrieves information,
and leverages their tools
and what kind of questions it can answer.
Most of the time,
when working with AI
applications like this,
when you're using foundation models,
actually, the first thing you should check
if you have any kind of
unexpected output is your prompt.
Because that's a lot of the time
where you can start seeing
the quickest improvements.
So, for this specific agent,
we're gonna tell the agent
that you are a gameplay expert.
Your job, your expertise
includes anything around game mechanics,
and we're gonna let it know
that it has access to a knowledge base,
and we have specific instructions
telling it how to leverage
the knowledge base,
and how we want it to
query the knowledge base
and return information
whether it found sufficient
information or not.
Now, this is a basic Strands agent.
Now, the next thing we have to do
is we define
our
AgentCore,
the next thing we wanna do
is to be able to deploy this
to Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
And so for that, what we
would need to do is one,
we need to use this Bedrock
AgentCore application.
Basically, what this is is a wrapper
to give it all the tools
that it needs to be to deploy
to an AgentCore Runtime.
And the reason that we need this is,
think about how many of you
have used Docker before?
So in Docker,
if you wanna make something
web service enabled,
you need to basically make it
into some kind of web server
using either something
like FastAPI or like Flask.
This is the Bedrock AgentCore
like flavor of that.
But you can also use the other frameworks,
like for example, FastAPI if
you would like to as well.
But this is a really
easy way to get started.
And then with that, the
last thing that you need
for your main logic is
you just need to have
your app.entrypoint, and
that's gonna tell your runtime
like where your main function is.
And that is how you
create your first agent,
and it's ready to go to
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
And so, then when you want to deploy it,
you have a few different options,
you can do it through the console,
or you can use our CLI for AgentCore
where you will just configure
it, and in the background,
it's gonna create all the
resources that it needs
to deploy it to a Docker container.
And then as a result,
it'll give you a endpoint,
and you'll use that endpoint
to invoke it in your application.
(people chattering distantly)
Now, the next, this with
Strands and AgentCore,
one of the things I've
really appreciated about it
is the fact that since it's so
intuitive to use,
once you've created one
good agent, you can really,
it becomes even faster and
faster to create the other agents
because you don't really
have to change that much.
And I'm gonna prove that
to you by showing you
a different agent.
This one is our strategy agent.
And so, I mentioned before, this one,
for every agent, every
Strands agent, we have tools,
our model, our system prompt.
And we can see here that
not a lot has changed.
We still have the same
code for our Bedrock model.
We have the system prompt present,
and then we have
our MCP server.
And the only thing that's different here
is we have a different tag
because we're using a
different knowledge base,
and then our system prompt.
Instead of telling it that
it's a gameplay agent,
we're saying that it's a strategy agent,
and it has access to strategy documents
instead of game design documents.
But that's really all the difference.
And so, now we're gonna talk about
how we can use the tool Kiro
to
making more agents even faster.
- [Sam] Awesome!
So, who here has used Kiro before?
Just me? Okay, cool.
So, inside of Kiro, obviously,
it's just like an IDE,
like anyone else's IDE.
You have obviously like your editor,
you can change things down
here, like for example,
what type of language you have.
You can also change like
your auto completion rules,
your formats, your themes.
But the most coolest part about it
is you have the new chat feature over here
on the right hand side.
Now, there's two different types of chat
that you can have with Kiro.
First off is the vibe section.
If you wanna vibe with Kiro,
that's great, if you wanna do
like small code changes or
even single file changes.
But for me, I want to
build a brand new feature,
or in this case, I
wanna build a new agent.
Obviously, the agent is probably
a little bit of overkill
for spec-driven development,
but we're just gonna be
using it as an example.
A better example in the future would be
instead of having me
build out a single agent,
it'll be building out
all the separate agents
and just me giving some
specs around like, hey,
here are the MCP servers
that you should use.
So, inside of here,
I have a prompt already
pre-populated that I'm gonna run,
but I'll be explaining
you guys that prompt
while it's running.
So, inside of this prompt, I'm telling it
to only use the folder
Kiro building, so that way,
it doesn't get any of the wonderful code
that we have prepared
already for you today.
I will only work in
that side of that folder
and place all the new code
in the new lore agent basic.
I've asked it just create two tasks
just for demo purposes today,
and we'll see if it follows
through on that today.
Other than that, the prompt was hey,
build out a new agent
based off of the old agents
that we've already created,
and then it will create
a lore pump for us,
and make sure to install any
needed packages, for example,
if we're using Strands today,
it'll go ahead and do that.
So, while that's running,
I will review the new requirements
the (indistinct) created.
So, the requirements
document overview is that
this is really, if you
were to design a paper
that you give your executive,
this is what a requirements
doc would look like for them.
It would really contain things like,
oh, what is a lore agent supposed to be?
What is a Strands SDK?
You would hand that off
to like your manager,
your BD, and they'd be like,
"Aww, this is really helpful
because they would not
understand these terms."
For us engineers, we'd be
like, "All right, yeah,
requirements looks good enough to me,
and we move on to the
more important section,
which is the design doc."
The design doc contains all
the implementation details
and the requirement stocks
that we would typically
look at as engineers.
So inside of here, you'll
see the key components
that we want to have,
the different interfaces
and interactions that we
want to have with that,
so it will give a little bit more detail,
for example, what an app
entry point would be,
the lore agent functions, give
different connections for MCP
and give some variable names
that we might want to utilize.
For example, I pasted it in
here, what knowledge base
I want to use, and was able
to keep moving forward.
After that, we like gave a,
for example, the Bedrock model
we should use, the system prompts,
and it'll kinda give us a
detailed overview of exactly how
the implementation of something
like this would happen.
Obviously, with more complex projects,
this doc gets really cool
and a lot of detail in there.
And to be honest, it is a
great first step to documenting
what you've built in the new
feature that you've built.
After this is all done
and it takes all this
entire design doc in,
it will then create a task list.
Inside of this task list,
it'll contain all the different tasks
that we have to do to build this thing.
So, you notice that we
only have two tasks,
but typically on a lot of other features,
we are gonna have longer tasks
or even more tasks in this,
and even some subtasks.
So, we'll go ahead and get
started on the first task itself,
and it will go ahead and run that task.
At any point if it has any questions,
or if it needs to run any
commands, it'll ask me
before doing so.
Well obviously, we just released today,
Hero Anonymous or
Autonomous, which allows us
to run things in the background
or even sign GitHub actions
or GitHub pull requests, I should say.
And
GitHub feature requests inside of Kiro.
So, it will do the entire
thing behind the scenes
instead of something like in the CLI.
I personally like to use it in the CLI
when I'm actively building something,
'cause I get that feedback
right then and there,
and I can change things as I see fit.
So, the first task is now complete,
and while that second
task gets kicked off,
one of the really cool
things that it does,
it gives you a nice little
overview of what it has done.
So, inside of here, it tells
me it created a folder,
configured the Bedrock model,
gave me an initial prompt,
gave me the MCP client
that's supposed to connect,
gave me environment
variables and error handling,
and entry points as well.
Afterwards, the next task, obviously,
I've made this very simple for Kiro,
is gonna be building
out a requirements TIC.
So, it's gonna go through
that file it created
and validate that all the requirements
that we need for Python are
gonna be properly installed
and configured for us to
utilize for this project.
So after that, we are able
to have a brand new agent
spun up with Kiro.
Saves us a lot of time and
makes our lives a lot easier.
Obviously, that was a very simple task
and there's a lot more cool complex tasks
that you can kind of do,
but just wanted to use that
as an example of how you can use Kiro.
Now that we've kind of talked
about how we build the agents,
let's dive into our next section.
Let's take a look at what
it looks like to combine
all these things.
So obviously, we can go in
here, and go ahead and create
a brand new project.
Inside this project,
we're gonna fill out this
just like we did last time.
We're gonna use our same
doc for the Elven Expansion.
We're gonna go in here and
paste that document in.
And this time, we're gonna configure it
with the analyst thing.
Notice how we're not able
to select any other agents
because all the other agents
are gonna be available
in the analyst.
The analyst is just
gonna use them as tools.
So, we're gonna go ahead
and create that project.
Once again, using some
wonderful demo magic,
I already have done this ahead of time.
So, what we have here is this
wonderful review of this document.
And inside of here, it gives
us a high level overview.
This gives us the three
different agents that it called,
and gave us a reason why or
why we should not proceed
with this project.
For example, the lore,
as I mentioned before,
does not fit at all.
Elves do not fit into
the context of this game.
So, we're able to kind of look at that,
evaluate that, and immediately see that.
After that, we can literally dive
into each of the consistencies
just like the original three prompts are.
But this time, it's all
available one-sided doc.
And so, you can kind of see
that each one of these areas,
it kind of gives us a
nice little overview,
and we're able to
identify different themes
and dive into it as well.
One thing you'll notice as
well is that it will give us
the entire tokens that are outputted,
as well as the response time,
as well as the average cost
for that document review.
After that, we can then
ask additional prompts
to back to this.
For example, can we dive
into how agents can be used
instead of elves, which is a valid race
inside of "New World."
What this does is then it takes a look at
all the different gameplay agents
and stuff like that afterwards,
and is able to dive into, oh!
This change that I've made
is able to then align and move forward.
If I continue having a
conversation with this bot,
it'll continue to be able to create
and design things for me.
So, next thing I asked is, hey,
can you create a quest around this?
And what it did is instead
of calling all the agents,
it started utilizing just certain agents.
So, now that we have strategy
pretty much satisfied,
this one, it just went ahead
and called gameplay and lore!
And it built an entire quest
around the gameplay and lore.
And it was able to design
a entire quest for me.
And what I can use this
for is I can keep iterating
and build a whole a design doc around this
and ask more questions.
And as you are all familiar,
if you've ever written
requirements docs before,
this is a collaborative process
that usually when you give
your first design doc,
unless you've written it so many times
or you've been like preparing
it for months ahead,
you always get feedback on your docs.
And this is just that iteration
and the ability to ask
for more details,
and to continue that
iteration process offline
or more streamlined.
So, after multiple different
things, you'll see that
we have different token
utilizations, response times,
as well as estimated costs
that are all outputted
from the Strands SDK,
that you can easily use
through the metrics.
With this, we obviously
are just trying to combine
all the agents.
So, there's some areas
that we can improve upon,
with like for example memory.
But we'll dive into
that a little bit later.
Let's first talk about how
we build this with Strands.
- [Christina] Alright.
Okay, so I like to.
So, I like to, I'm gonna
bring up a picture,
'cause I think this is the
best way to demonstrate
how our orchestrator is built.
So,
this one is gonna be
a little bit different
because this agent is not
gonna be directly retrieving
information from the knowledge bases,
but instead, it's going to delegate
to our our specialized agents.
So, the way that we have
this one designed is instead,
we're going to be having our main agent,
our Game Analyst Agent.
This is gonna be defined same as before,
except this time, its
tools are going to be
the specialized agents.
And with that, the way we'll
be doing this is we'll be,
our orchestrator, what's gonna happen
is when it gets our query,
like a game design proposal,
its job is gonna be to break
down the design proposal
and to figure out which
questions need to be answered
to evaluate it across gameplay,
lore, strategy, and QA.
It'll delegate to those
specialized agents to go and grab
that information for it.
And then, those agents will
return it to the orchestrator,
and the orchestrator will
synthesize it and create
a more
concise response based
off of all of its findings
with full visibility
across all of the core competencies.
So, now let's take a look at
how that is built in the code.
So, go to the game analyst.
So, we can see here, it
is very, very similar
to what we had before.
We have our model that is still defined,
still using Anthropic Claude's on it.
We are going to have our system prompt
and I'll just make this
a little bit bigger,
but this time in our system prompt,
we're going to be saying
you are a game analyst,
and your job is to take in
game design documents or questions,
and you need to analyze all game designs
for the core competencies.
With that, we're gonna tell
it that it has access to
the following tools
that we want it to use.
So, for anything around
lore, we're gonna send it
to the lore agent.
For anything around gameplay,
we're gonna have it send
questions to the gameplay agent.
And same for the strategy agent as well.
And then with that, we
have, we're now leveraging
the other type of tool
that I alluded to earlier,
our custom tools.
And that is all done by
adding this tool decorator.
And so, for each specialized agent,
we're just gonna have a function
that invokes them using the Boto3 Library.
And that is how we would use those agents,
and then with that, we
still have the same stuff,
we got our main function right
here with our entry point.
And that initialization
that was up at the top
for our wrapper to make it
ready for an AgentCore Runtime.
Right, now we can go to the.
(participant chattering distantly)
No, that's the next (indistinct) part.
- [Sam] So, now that we have
all our game analysts
ready to rock and roll,
now we wanna look at adding Memories.
And why do you think
memories are important?
Well first of all, they give us access to
the ability to communicate with the thing
and remember our prompts, and
everything else like that.
So right now, inside of my agent
that I have built up today,
I've actually decided to send
the entire conversation
history every single time
with the agent.
That includes that original document
and all these original,
the document feedbacks
that I've gotten as well.
So, as I continue to iterate
and continue to build on this doc,
that number of tokens, input
tokens are gonna skyrocket.
Every single time I send another update,
it gives me another prompt
back or a big document back.
That means that I'm storing
more and more detail
back to each individual project, right?
So that's not helpful.
On top of that, each of the
different agents underlying
are going back to the knowledge bases
and querying for more data.
For example, if I asked to
add agents instead of elves,
and it had to go look up the ancients,
it's gonna have to do that again
when I asked to design that quest,
it's gonna have to go back to the more
and go pull all that detail.
Because of the fact that
it pulled it at one time
and didn't store it anywhere.
So, since I'm only
sending the chat details,
I did not remember that at all.
That's where things like Memories
can come in handy, right?
It can remember, oh I
already pulled that details
from the knowledge base,
I already remember what ancients are.
It might need to go
look up certain details
around the ancients,
maybe it didn't store
like the details around
what region they live in,
but it's stored like what they are.
So instead of doing a deep
lookup into ancients in general,
it might have to do lookups
into only specific areas of that race.
So, what we'll look at here is that
we'll do the same exact thing
with the project spin up.
This time, we'll create a new project,
and as time, we'll see
that we can select analyst,
and we'll actually turn on Memory Enabled.
Once again, I won't go ahead and run this
'cause I've already
run this ahead of time,
and you can see that
we already had a response
back with the Memories.
We're then gonna be able to read through
the entire response, dive into it,
and then you can see that number of tokens
between the two are very similar.
That's because of the fact that
this is the first analysis,
it's reading the entire document
for the first time, right?
It's supposed to use
everything it has available.
But as we continue to
call it as I did today,
oh, did not like that for some reason.
Lemme go back to this real quick.
So, as it said, as I continue to ask
the same exact prompts
for the sake of this demo,
I asked it the same exact
prompts of designing
a quest around it.
I asked it to use the ancients.
I've proceeded to go
through the entire process,
you'll notice at the very bottom here
that our token usage is actually dropped.
And that's because the fact
that we're using Memories.
We're no longer having to
query our knowledge base
every single time.
We're no longer having
to read the document
every single time.
We're just being able to utilize
what we've already called
in a different manner
and be able to provide more
and more things back and forth.
The other thing that's also
interesting to look at is that
the response time starts to drop as well.
Because I start understanding
the knowledge base,
I start understanding the
knowledge of what is happening.
Obviously, you can also
improve that response times
by using things like specialized agents.
Definitely like the Nova training models
that just came out today.
Those are all different areas
that you also can improve
that response times,
but Memories just dropped
our response times
by over 80 seconds, which is crazy.
So, by using Memories,
we're able to provide
a better response time, as
well as using less tokens,
which obviously drives
your cost down as well.
So, I'll hand it off to Christina
to talk a little bit more
about how you can actually enable Memories
and utilize that, awesome.
- [Christina] Okay, so lemme
go back to my pictures.
I got another lovely picture for you guys.
So,
the way that we are implementing Memories
is at a few different levels.
I talked about this a little bit before,
but we have our project-specific Memories
that are gonna be storing facts.
And then, we have our Session Memories,
our Session Memories and
our User Preference Memories
to help out our Game Analyst Agent.
So for that,
our orchestrator is very similar to
the way before, except for,
we have a little,
we have our memory integration.
So, what that requires is
we're actually gonna add
a couple extra tools.
So, we'll start with
the specialized agents.
At the specialized agents level,
what we'll be doing is you would add,
in order to integrate Memories,
is you're gonna use tools to,
you're gonna define tools that
are gonna be able to restore
and retrieve memories.
And then, you're gonna have memory hooks.
This is gonna be specific to Strands,
if you think about it
like this, in an agent,
an agent has a life cycle.
And in this life cycle,
you have different phases
from when the agent is initialized
to when the conversation is
over, and the agent is done.
With Strands hooks, you can customize
the logic of how your agents interact
and how they function at
each point in their lifetime.
And so with hooks, we're
gonna define how it stores
and retrieves Memories
with the interaction
between the agent and Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore Memories.
And so, at the specialized agent level,
we're going to be leveraging,
we're gonna be using
Memories like a cache.
So, the whole idea is we want to reduce
how often the specialized agent
has to go all the way back
to the knowledge base and
look for the information,
and we'll have it do
instead its first check
and see if it's already answered
a similar question before
or retrieved like the information
that it's looking for before.
And only if it can't
find that information,
in its Memories,
then it'll go back to the
data source and go as normal.
Additionally, we have our game analyst,
is gonna be leveraging Session Memories,
so at the beginning of its
lifecycle, we're gonna have it
load X number of previous
conversations into its context
to provide more information
on previous conversations.
And then, we also have it
leveraging user preferences
to provide that more
personalized experience.
So, now let's dive back into the code
and see what that looks like.
So, I know I've been saying this a lot,
(chuckling) but a lot of this is gonna be
very similar to what we had before.
And the reason I keep
mentioning this is because,
what I really want you
guys to get out of this
is just how easy it is to work
with the Strands framework.
With this, we still have the
model defined just as before,
and we have our system prompt.
This is actually, spoiler alert,
this is gonna be the most different piece.
You can see we've got some
extra like notations in here
and all of that.
And actually, this was
an experiment that I had
when I was building out this agent to see
how much we can improve
the agent's performance
with just a prompt, who all
enjoys prompt engineering
and feels like confident
in their abilities with it. (chuckling)
See? Not very many of us,
I'm in the same boat as you.
But with tools like Amazon Bedrock,
you don't have to be an
expert in prompt engineering,
and I'm gonna show you why.
So, I'm gonna go over into the console
and show you a new tool that I love,
which is our Prompt
Manager, Prompt Builder.
So with that, I actually
took the original prompt
from our original agent,
and I pasted it into here.
And you can tell it
what model you're using,
and it will optimize the
prompt for you for that model.
And so, I actually just
took this and copied
and pasted it into the code, and I got
immediate results from
it, it was really cool.
So,
one of the main differences.
And then the other piece that's different,
is we now just tell, so now
we have Memories, right?
So, all we have to do now
is tell the system prompt
that it has access to memory tools.
It's very straightforward.
And so, we tell it, "Hey,
go check the Memories first,
and for like the
information that you need,
and then if you don't
have the information,
then go about your job as normal."
And so, we have that here,
and we can see we still
have our same tools.
And then finally, the last thing we have
is we just are going to initialize,
we're gonna just basically say now
instead of just leveraging
the custom tools
that we had before, where
we said we have that logic
to go and invoke the other
agents, we also are telling it
to use the memory tools as
part of its like tool belt.
And that's all you really need to do.
And then you go about as normal,
you have your AgentCore
Runtime initialized,
I believe that is up here.
And you have your entry point.
And that's like the entire magic
behind the whole thing. (laughing)
So,
with that, we'll go back
to the presentation.
(Christina shuffling)
So,
well first, I want to talk about,
I think I accidentally
pressed a button earlier.
So, just a recap of what we did today.
So, what we did was we
learned how to build
Specialized Agents and
Orchestrator Agents in Strands.
And we saw through our demo of how
by leveraging AI agents,
we can accelerate game designers
in their innovation cycles by
providing them with a place
to get quick and early feedback,
so that they can basically have
a more fine-tuned design proposal
for that human interaction
with the game analyst,
so we can reduce all the back and forth.
Additionally, we saw specialized
agents working together,
and alongside the designers and analysts
to provide that
collaborative intelligence of
the AI information retrieval,
plus a humans industry experience.
And then finally,
because all of our agents
are gonna have access to
a standardized knowledge
base, we're able to create
a more unbiased, standardized
baseline assessment
to kind of have a predictable
kind of starting point
for all of the design proposals.
And then, if there are three key takeaways
that we would want you
to walk away with today,
these are the three I would
say are the most important one.
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore simplifies
the development of production ready agents
by providing you with runtimes
that are scalable and secure,
and all the tools that you need
to continue to help your agents evolve
in a secure and performant manner.
Additionally, you can enhance
your agent performance
and user experiences with
AgentCore memory by reducing,
by increasing the performance
through lower latency,
by using it as a cache,
and providing more
personalized experiences.
And additionally, and
the last one is you can
accelerate your design
teams by equipping them
with the tools to transform
subjective feedback
into objective insights.
And this will enable
faster and more confident
game design decisions.
So, some next steps, we've
left some links for here.
Be sure to look out for
our GitHub repository.
We do have it posted, and
we're continuing to add to it.
We have, if you are interested in having
any more hands-on tutorials
with Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
this is a really great place
to start with the samples.
I personally actually use them
to learn how to use AgentCore.
And then finally, if you want
a really cool hands-on
workshop with another use case
for Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
check out the Autonomous
Live-Ops AI agents
for Dynamic Gaming Experiences session.
I actually sat in on the dry runs for it
and it was really cool.
So, please do check it
out if you have time.
And I wanna open it up for questions,
and thank you all so much for being here.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Woo!